okay i'm just gonna pick up where i left
off so okay so what we we'd been looking
at right was um we're looking at this
rank one matrix estimation problem
we have a model
like this we observe a data matrix a
we'd like to recover our signal
uh v
and so um
what we looked at is using an amp
algorithm to do this right and so
uh the amp algorithm takes the the
following form it's our standard a and p
but we've replaced you know the w
with our data matrix a
okay and so um
what we motivated by kind of looking at
the distribution of you know at least
the the first iterate
uh was that you know what we'll find is
a state evolution like the the following
um and uh with the state evolution we
get uh our main theoretical results so
uh the the theory is
is similar to to what we have for the
original or the standard amp so under
similar assumptions which are you know
assumptions on
regularity conditions about uh my
function ft
uh sort of assumptions on the empirical
distribution um
converging of like the signal and my
initialization uh we we get the
following result right so
for some pseudo lipschitz function that
now has two inputs which uh my signal
uh this is the the true signal right and
my matrix iterates then uh we get that
the the limit of uh this this sort of
pseudo-lipschitz loss
um is determined by my state evolution
uh values right so here
v is just a random variable
with the same distribution as uh my
signal and it's independent of z which
is just a standard gaussian random
variable
and the mu and the sigma are given by uh
the the state evolution
so in particular right um we can look at
some examples to make this
uh concrete so the first thing is what
if we take
uh you know my my pseudo lipschitz
function to be something like
the following right
um then then what is our theory
guarantee
right well it says that uh
the following so we have one over n
times
f t
x t minus
the
norm
accuracy or
successor
and now you optimize the ft to get
the best thing
yes yep
um so uh
okay so that's two slides from now um
all right so what we get is if we look
at some examples right so this guy
limits
to
the following it's an expectation
of f t
mu t v plus sigma t
gt
minus v
squared right
so this is just the result that uh you
know we we got from the the theory right
and then we can sort of um you know show
using the state evolution that this is
equal to sigma t plus one squared minus
two mu
t plus one over theta
plus one right so in short something
like the mean square error between the
estimate that i get for my a and p and
the true signal is determined by my
state evolution parameters right
these are just the mu and t from two
slides ago
same thing
maybe uh you're not interested in mean
square error you're instead interested
in an overlap sort of metric right well
we can use the same thing the state
evolution says something about the inner
product and also about these norms
so uh this for example is going to limit
to something like
2 plus 1
over
theta sigma t plus one right
okay
and so um
do you remind us what's sigma t
so these are just these guys uh that are
come from the the
so it's the
recursion um
right exactly so
is it basically saying that
when you're analyzing mp you could
imagine that
you're just walking in one dimension but
you have like fresh noise the w is like
a fresh noise in each iteration and
and whatever you get in one dimension
the accuracy you get in
uh yeah i think so you know there's some
horrific sort of uh like the proof i
gave there's horrific proofs uh that'll
motivate things like this where it's
just like if you instead analyze the
iteration where with each iteration t
you put a new matrix in
then this kind of this sort of state
evolution will pop out and you'll see
uh you know we get the the same thing
and then the argument again is like okay
well the role of the unsucker term is to
act as if we get a new random matrix
with each iteration
um and then yeah so essentially right so
uh
basically then uh you know when we look
at uh
where am i
going other way
something like this right now we just
have a one-dimensional kind of
thing that we're looking at so
exactly it's i mean it's sort of
like even here right you can see that
like what you want is this to be big
compared to
this
right and so
then what you try to do is just
since the the mu and the the sigma
depend on
the f
can we find an f that optimizes that
ratio
um
okay
right so okay so we get expectation of
this term squared which is the sigma t
plus one squared
right so
this guy
then you get the one comes from expected
value v squared and then the cross term
gives you
okay right so uh
okay
what we've all been waiting for how do
we choose ft right um so
okay uh the
what what uh i suggest to do here and um
you know this extends beyond just like
the matrix estimation problem but um
essentially you want to choose the ft to
minimize or to maximize your
signal-to-noise ratio so here i'm going
to define my signal-to-noise ratio to
just be the ratio of the the mu and the
sigma right which is kind of motivated
for many reasons right uh
we can see that you know my
uh
sort of iterate x t
looks like this
right so we'd like
mu to be big relative to sigma we can
also see that you know asymptotically
the overlap between
my estimate and my truth
depends on this ratio so maximizing this
ratio is something we'd like to do
that's exactly what you want i mean i
see that it goes in the right direction
but
if i want actually the optimal recovery
is that the same as optimizing the this
ratio if you go back to the peak decider
if they want to get the minimum the best
means where they are
then
it's not ex is it exactly that
yeah so what you actually find is that
yes uh well
if you maximize this what you find is
that you get the conditional
distribution denoiser
and you
this maximizes both the overlap and the
mean square error
and like even if you care about a a
metric that's not
either of those two you should
essentially still run amp with this in
it and then
you know kind of at the end uh
denoise and the or you know noise on the
the way you you want somehow
so
that makes sense
so
okay in general when
uh folks run amp with this uh sort of
conditional distribution denoiser
um
this is referred to as bayes amp so for
various reasons right this is called the
bayes denoiser and bayes amp is when
amts run with this denoiser so sometimes
when people talk about amp they're
they're actually thinking about amt
specifically with this denoiser but you
can choose other functions too so
for example you know
uh when amp was originally studied for
compressed sensing sometimes folks would
run amp with like the soft thresholding
function here right which might still be
something you want to do if you want a
sparse solution but um in terms of
maximizing signal-to-noise ratio uh this
is the
the right idea
okay so um i wanted to make the point
that okay so now uh
if we use optimal denoising which i just
mean we so i'm calling the function ft a
denoising function right uh so the idea
being that you know uh
it
ft uh in our algorithm takes as input um
you know terms like this
right so its function should be to
denoise
them right um so it's often referred to
as a denoising function and so if we run
um our amp algorithm again thinking
about this rank one matrix estimation
problem with this denoiser then it turns
out that my my state evolution
simplifies so earlier remember this is
the state evolution where we're um
looking at but you can kind of see that
if these are conditional distribution
uh things um then you know uh thing
things
uh become more simple so what happens is
um
with that specific ft yeah
so the you're optimizing each uh
mutant in each ft conditional on the
previous ft
like your ultimate it seems like you're
optimizing sequentially
um
uh like you're optimizing
because they all depend on each other
but when you're optimizing it you're not
like defense then correctly how you
chose it
you're not looking forward you're only
looking you know you're just optimizing
it for this
uh i mean
well um i mean is that is that optimal
actually or next one is increasing
function yeah but but if i care about if
i know that i only care about what
happens you know and what happens
iteration 100. so i want to get the best
uh comma 100 right is it clear that i
should
choose the optimal
uh
you know the optimal number one number
two
the last one if they are
sigma t separately but you're saying
that if i improve gamma 3 then i'm going
to necessarily if i give you a better
mute neutrin sigma 3 that gets a better
gamma 3 then you'll be able to do better
for colorful maybe one way to look at it
is the scale it's kind of free right if
you multiply f by something
you and the sigma doesn't matter so you
really want to talk about the ratio of
even sigma not
the individual values oh but okay i
guess i don't see it because it's not
just mu and sigma it's also definitely
look like some mu
times your signal plus some sigma times
your noise
and once you know that it's a good idea
to increase mu relative to sigma as
possible
so you don't so that i don't care about
the horizon
you can always say absorb one of mu and
sigma to f right because we are
optimizing
so you can decide
and sigma is always constant so now we
are very cautious
it's a one-dimensional
okay so um
this is kind of what uh
andrea was saying right so when we use
the optimal denoiser what we actually
see is that the state evolution
simplifies to just
uh a single recursion right so now we
can think of the state evolution as just
a recursion on the signal to noise ratio
right um and uh
it takes the following form right so we
we initialize with some gamma naught
that's based on our initial
uh
correlation with the the signal right
and then we update uh with respect to
some mmse function that just calculates
the bayes risk with respect to l2 loss
uh based on the the previous
snr
and so
uh what one can show
is that
uh if we think about the the state
evolution iterating now in t
uh the state evolution is going to
converge to the smallest strictly
positive uh fixed point right so
this tells us that if we run the amp
you know our performance metrics are
going to be determined by this strictly
smallest
fixed point
and so um i bring this up because this
is kind of
right
yeah smallest is worse right so you know
this is our snr so we'd like it to be
big so if we have multiple fixed points
what's going to happen is amp goes to
the one that's not as good
um
and so this is this is how we kind of
tie in these amp algorithms to the uh
sort of computational limits of problems
right so
uh to do this what we want to do is
compare this to the information
theoretic limit of the problem right so
if we just you know want to think about
something like uh minimizing
the l2 distance between you know
the true signal and some estimator that
i have that takes is you know the that
uses my data matrix right we know that
the way to minimize this mean square
error is just by choosing uh my
estimator to be the conditional
expectation
and so um the performance of this
estimator has been uh
analyzed before by you know jean and
uh large and uh mia lane and others and
and
what they show is that uh the
performance of
this bayes estimator is actually
described by sort of the same fixed
point equation right so it's also
described by the fixed point of you know
what we just saw as our state evolution
uh recursion over here right so
this guy
and this guy sorry i
my bad
this should be a
gamma novel
okay
but
what we see for the the bayes uh
estimator is that um
it's going to attain a fixed point of
this uh equation that's described by
some potential function
and so uh the details of the potential
function are not necessary but you know
we know how it's going to perform based
on characteristics of the the problem
so um
what the kind of conclusion is right is
so if our state evolution has one fixed
point right then uh
great
amp attains it and that fixed point also
characterizes the performance of the
the base estimator right so amp is doing
as good as it can right um hence there
is no like statistical computational gap
here
um but you know on on the other hand
right if there are multiple fixed points
uh like we pointed out
um then
you know uh
amt is going to hit the the one that's
not as good right and so
uh
could be subpar in those settings so i'm
going to give an example where it hits
uh something that
is not as good as the the bayes risk
okay but i just wanted to comment
briefly to make this um
a feasible
algorithm i needed to address the fact
that i sort of cheated when i uh
initialized the algorithm so
uh in the beginning right i assumed that
my initialization for the amt algorithm
was correlated with my signal v
and so um
you can kind of see why we we need this
to be true so uh for example if um so
here this is v my random variable that's
distributed in the same way as my signal
so if my signal has mean zero elements
and instead i i initialize with
something that's not correlated with v
then what happens well
we can see that that you know the the
signal strength term in my state of
elation state evolution my mu one term
um just exactly equals zero right
and so what's going to happen is uh you
know you we run the state evolution but
this mu
is going to continue to equal zero right
and so
i mean that's bad right because you know
the overlap metric for example had that
mu uh in the numerator so if it's equal
to zero then this is saying that amp is
giving us a result that you know isn't
correlated with the signal at all so
the amp
you know is is functionally useless
right
so
uh if we have a a mean zero signal then
we need something that correlates with
the the truth um i'll mention if the
mean of the signal is not equal to zero
then uh you're all good because you can
just
initialize with like a a constant vector
or something
um but it turns out uh you know that
what you can do if you're in this
situation where your your
signal has mean zero then you can just
use your initialization as the principal
eigenvector of your data matrix
and so um
it turns out that you know uh
well
why is this a good idea right well
random matrix theory tells us a lot of
things about the principal eigen
vector and in particular in this problem
it tells us that
uh if the the signal strength in the
problem is large enough
right then our principal eigenvector is
going to be
uh correlated with my my true signal uh
at some level and you know
if the if the signal strength is is not
then my noise just
totally washes out the the signal and i
don't get any correlation but the idea
is okay so let's imagine we're in this
regime where the principal eigenvector
is useful
for us right then uh what we can do is
just let's okay initialize a and p with
this principal eigenvector
and so um
it turns out that this works in practice
uh but you know since
now we are not in the setting where my
initialization is independent of you
know the matrix that i'm i'm using
uh to run the amp the standard theory no
longer holds so the theory that i built
up until now assumed
uh independence of the initialization
and and my matrix but this is no longer
the the case here if we initialize with
the principal eigenvector but um the the
happy ending to this story at least is
that um you know the theory still goes
through in the ways you would expect it
would uh due to uh ramji and andrea's
recent work
so should we think of it
as if
the heavy lifting in some sense is far
is by the principal eigenvector and then
amp fixes so it provides a warm start
for mp and then amp kind of fixes to to
get the best
estimator from this approximate version
obviously
so
i guess the question is like you really
need a correlation that is independent
of n right that's to get things going is
that uh so you need some vector that has
a
significant correlation with your signal
that is independent of n so that's
so basically md requires some some type
of uh warm stuff
uh
so i mean
um
yeah i mean i don't i don't think that's
necessarily the right way to think about
it right because like i was saying you
know if just you have like non-zero
uh mean here then
you
you know well no but it's not zero
correlation
yeah um
okay yeah here is another way to say
this
amp for logan iterations using
f the linear
function what you will be doing is the
power method and will compute basically
an approximation of the leading
eigenvector
and then i'll change the function to the
optimal base function right
so i'm doing a strange
so i believe it will work i just want to
get like an intuition whether i should
think of it as basically a two-step
algorithm where the first step you need
to get like a warm start and something
that has a constant correlation and then
you do this base optimal thing to
really nail down the the two maximum
correlations that you could possibly get
given the signal the point is that the
base optimal thinner meaning is the
linear function assumption because if
you think of if you have a random
variable class a humongous noise
sorry just to understand that is the
follow-up result only for like it's only
for the plus minus one like uniform
prior right like if you have like a
sparse prior and stuff then you would
like you need significantly higher
signal than r for
but if you don't pass the spectral
pressure
that is the testing still
right so if you don't pass this
threshold that fixes point is stable and
you don't know of any output number sure
but i'm just trying to understand that
in some sense the destination
corresponds to the one which corresponds
to getting a good initialization
okay so um
right okay so
all right with the spectral
initialization then like we have a
a full algorithm uh to run right
um and so here's like some examples of
just you know
what happens with this the the
performance of amp versus like
the bayes estimator right so if we're in
this setting right where our signal
elements are equal probable 0 1 or plus
minus 1 right so this is a case where
it's mean zero so we need to use the
spectral initialization
uh well in this case uh amp with the
spectral initialization has
i t information theoretically optimal
performance
um as another example right if we think
about an initialization where the values
take plus or minus some value a
with probabilities epsilon of one minus
epsilon uh so that we remain mean zero
and variance one
then what we can show is that the state
evolution is going to have multiple
fixed points and
mp's going to perform strictly worse
than the
the bayes optimal uh estimator
and so there's like a little caveat here
right that amp with spectral
initialization needs the
uh
our signal strength the theta to be
bigger than than one and
uh you know the base
work without but um that's the
yeah for the second problem
you know that is it believe that for
that specific problem it's aft achieves
the algorithmically optimal uh threshold
or it's so below that it's
algorithmically believed not to be
uh
some people have uh made the conjecture
i think what she calls here here plus
minus one with priority stops
sometimes we have a reason to believe
that there is no element so
it's a question i can give a sense of
how
he looks like
this and also how
how
how different is the the optimal thing
from the main thing does this like the
spectral
approximation
ah
both of them gets mostly at first
yeah so um
if you just take the spectral
initialization uh
there's like an example in the paper i
mean the ms like the mean square error
of the anti-algorithm is like you know
strictly below the the limiting messy or
like the the msc of like the
spectral initialization so the amps does
better right
like if you you're saying if you just
take yeah
yeah
how much like how many more samples do i
need in order to get the same
performance
um
yeah
small constant factor or is it like
[Music]
so
you know all the errors are constants
right
so but you know you can look at how they
go to zero
okay the scenario
goes down like
need like i mean if you're doing an amp
and i'm doing spectral learning you know
many more samples just to get the same
one right okay
and how does it
no no
yeah it's a long starter
all right um so i will
uh let's see
okay i'm gonna um
mention just two generalizations and
then i'll say like 10 minutes on
generalized linear models so
the first extension is that you know uh
we can extend all of this to a
non-symmetric version of amp so if it's
if your matrix is not no longer a goe
matrix but now you're just an iid
gaussian matrix
there's um an amt for you too right so
now uh since we're not symmetric we have
two
uh iterates um they you know sort of
mirror each other um
and you know the amp the theory kind of
looks the same as before
there's
not a lot of point to to stay on this
you can prove it you know directly by
con considering the
two different iterations in the same way
you consider the symmetric one or you
can reduce
the non-symmetric version to a symmetric
version and use the original theory
you can also extend this to
matrix iterates so
now you know we have our two
step iteration but now we're thinking
about the bt and the ht no longer being
vectors but instead being matrices
um
of of fixed size and you know everything
kind of goes through like you expect you
know the derivatives are now jacobians
and these sorts of things and you can
kind of you know with some practice
guess the theory and the state evolution
and and so on and it turns out that like
the amp with matrix iterates so uh this
is uh
javin mard and and montanari analyze
this
um in the beginning it's useful it um
for example is the way to prove uh the
generalized approximate message passing
uh that i'll approve next so
um these extensions exist
but you know they're
more or less like as you would expect
somehow
okay so um for the last like 15 minutes
uh
i will just say some words about
generalized linear models
um so
uh here my my idea is um
okay i have uh some signal
that i'll call x now
and let's assume that it's iid its
elements are id according to some
distribution
i have some output y
and now i have a
matrix that's iid gaussian and this is
all connected via some
uh function uh
q so the idea right is that uh my output
is generated by some
uh conditional distribution here based
on
um
the the linear measurements of of my
signal right and so
if this q
comes from an exponential
uh dispersion family statisticians call
this a generalized linear model
[Music]
uh yeah we'll see what we can get
through and i'll stop one as it seems
normal um thanks
okay so um
right so
generalized linear models right uh this
is a class that includes like standard
linear models it also includes things
like logistic regression and poisson
regression and phase retrieval
and and so on
um
okay so uh
right in in short i mean the intuition
for the the glms is kind of like you can
think about it as a two-step process
right so i produce an output from my
input signal x how do i do that well the
first step is i take linear measurements
of x through uh
my my iid gaussian matrix a
and then i observe my output based on
some conditional distribution
of y given those those linear
measurements right so this just includes
you know
other noise models for example than
additive gaussian noise or whatever
all right so um
okay so there's an amp algorithm to use
uh if you would like to recover the
signal in such models right and this is
called gamp uh or generalized amp
um and it looks like uh the following so
uh you're gonna initialize um
with some u not uh that's independent of
my id uh matrix a so for example i could
just take my u naught to b or my u zero
to be a constant value
uh constant vector rather and then um i
update my my amp algorithm in two steps
and so um
this should look a little bit like the
non-symmetric amp we saw three slides
ago but the difference is now you know
this function here with the g it
includes my my y which is my output
value so this complicates things a
little bit right because the y is
you know dependent on things like my my
matrix right and so um it turns out that
that for this uh generalized approximate
message passing algorithm uh that
uh sandeep ringan uh initially studied
um it has in fact a different state
evolution than just the the
non-symmetric
amp right so the fact that this y is
here and these functions changes the
dynamics of the algorithm
um
i'm not going to uh
like show you the state evolution
because it's kind of complicated but
it's there right it's the same idea it's
a deterministic recursion that tells us
something about the dynamics of the
algorithm itself
so um
okay so what i want to do in the last
little bit is okay i'm gonna just
discuss some of the theory for the
generalized approximate message passing
um i'm going to link uh
the gamp algorithm to convex
optimization problems
and then uh give some steps for how to
systematically derive
exact asymptotic expressions for
risk of estimators and glms that you
know when the estimators are
solutions to optimization problems
and so
uh you know i was gonna end with like
a nice example about uh showing
properties of the lasso estimator but i
don't think i i will i will just stop
after i've given some
uh systematic way to do this so um this
is the part of the talk where it's like
how do we use amp
to
give us statistical properties of
things like the lasso estimator right or
um you know like prague studied uh
logistic regression and these sorts of
things
[Music]
okay
all right so here's all i'm going to say
about the state evolution for the
general approximate uh message passing
um it's
in short you know what what the theory
shows is that uh the iterates of
this gamp
um have empirical distributions that
converge to
sorry so this should be like converges
to the distribution of this right where
um you know importantly the x in our
algorithm this gives us the estimate of
our
signal and our glm
so uh our uh you know what does it look
like well it basically looks like again
uh you know something that that's
the the distribution of the signal
itself uh and independent gaussian noise
so
uh where the the signal strength versus
the
noise is determined by this this state
evolution so
now you know it's like the state
evolution has four different values
they're all recursive um it's a little
bit complicated so we won't look at it
um
okay
and so
in general right like all of the the
same things we discussed before
kind of hold true for this this
generalized approximate message passing
algorithm so you know you can choose ft
and gt
uh by maximizing
snr's they give you a sort of condition
it suggests conditional distribution
denoisers
um you know the convergence statements
can be made about the joint
distributions of the iterates um
you know it can also be written in terms
of pseudo lipschitz functions and and so
on
and then you know there's also theory
for the spectral initialization uh here
which you know
similar to before when we were looking
at you know lowering matrix estimation
and if the signal has or rank one matrix
estimation the signal has mean zero you
need uh
some sort of smart initialization there
are settings here where you you do need
a smart initialization and um
marco and ramji uh
wrote the theory for this
um
i'm gonna skip this i think
okay so
what i want to do is um
link the gamp algorithm that i just
showed you to a convex optimization
problem and so the high level idea is
um you know if i have a convex
optimization problem in a specific form
then i can choose the ft and the gt in
my game algorithm in such a way that the
fixed points of the the game actually
are
minimizers of my my optimization problem
and so that's kind of the the program
i'm going to give you in the next few
minutes
so um the idea is the following so we
want to look at um
constrained optimization problems like
this and so the motivation is that you
know for
many of the estimators and glms uh
they're
you know computed
from some sort of optimization like this
so we have a we're optimizing a cost
function
um over my you know some some
signal x that we're constrained to to
have the correct
uh linear measurements and the structure
of the cost function
is that it decouples into
a sum over loss functions
so this is like my you know y minus ax
squared term you know uh and then also
penalty functions so this could be
something like
an l1 penalty right
okay so um the the the program right is
if your
loss function
decomposes into or sorry if your cost
function decomposes into this form then
we can
write a gap algorithm
such that the the fixed points of that
gap algorithm solve the optimization
okay
so um
right so i just wanted to give um some
examples
of uh you know
cost functions that have this form and
in particular you know the mle and the
map estimator both
do so you know what is the mle right
well
theta hat mle
x x-hat mle
right how do you calculate that well
it's just going to be um
the argument
over a sum
where uh you know it's the negative log
likelihood
right where my likelihood now is
described by this
uh qi function
similarly right if if
my
signal elements
are iid
according to some px
then my
maximum
posterior
estimators
we're going to uh optimize this but then
they'll have a term for the priors right
so it's going to be something like
arg men
with the constraints on the other side
other slide
y equals 1 to n negative log
ui
then plus
the sum of j equals 1 to d negative
yes
so these are you know two such
estimators that are solved as
you know
optimizers of the cost function with the
form that that we're interested in i
mean another one is like the lasso right
um or uh whatever many of your favorite
estimators probably have this one
okay
so um okay so what we want to do is
assume uh this is a little bit of a
sticking point in the analysis but we
assume that j and l so my loss and my
penalty are convex in their first uh
argument and if we can make that
assumption then we can design a gap
algorithm whose fixed points are the the
solutions
um and then the the you know how do we
use this well then the game theory uh
gives us exact high dimensional
asymptotics for such estimators
so long as we can prove that the
algorithm converges to its fixed points
and so that's going to be the
you know the strategy that we lay out
ahead
um so before i introduce the gamp
algorithm that solves uh
the optimization problem let's just
remember what a proximal operator is
right if we have a convex function m
that's a scalar function and some
parameter eta then my proximal operator
is also a scalar function that just
solves this minimization problem
and um you know it has a lot of nice
properties like it's lip shuts and um
non-decreasing and so
um
this is uh useful for us because it
turns out that
um
if we want uh to run a gantt algorithm
that solves the convex optimization
problem then what we should do is choose
the ft and the gt to be uh proximal
operators
so
um
yeah so this is uh you know so the the
form
of the ft that we need is is some sort
of proximal operator
that acts you know with respect to the
penalty function
and then the form of the gt that we need
is a proximal operator that acts with
respect to my loss
function there
um
uh
i maybe
won't say much
more about that but
the the sort of takeaway is if we use
these you know the the form is like i
don't think that informative um but you
know just let's
the the sort of what i want you to hear
i guess is that if we choose the f and g
correctly
then um what happens well uh this nice
thing happens which is um
that if we find a fixed point
uh of the gap algorithm so a fixed point
in terms of the u and the x iterates
um then
uh
that fixed point um evaluated in sort of
the the fixed point functions as well
solves the optimization problem right so
it's going to be a minimizer of
uh the optimization
and so um
okay so this is all uh you know like
well defined so um you know these are
lip shits by the the void result i just
showed
right um and since these are convex now
this is the solution of strongly convex
it's the minimizer strongly convex thing
so um
at all uh
it all checks out
um
okay
and so um
all right so
to to
wrap up
right what i wanted to do is okay so if
we know this is true
right then um
the kind of remaining point is that
we need to show that our game algorithm
actually converges to this fixed point
and if that's true
right then then what we can kind of do
is is push
the like
game theory these state evolution
performance guarantees onto the the
minimizer of the cost function right so
in particular if that minimizer is like
an estimator like the lasso estimator
then you know now if we can show that
our game algorithm
finds that uh
that estimator then
it sort of inherits the state evolution
guarantees right and so to wrap up i
just wanted to give a quick
general strategy for
um doing this and so
and uh the paper i mentioned earlier you
know we lay out this general strategy
and then we show that you know uh
the the results for the lasso and for m
estimator so the lasso was bayati and
matanari and the m estimator was donahoe
and montanari and uh correctness
the
uh pragya studied logistic regression
with the sort of strategy and so we show
that you know all of those sorts of
uh
works
use this same um kind of approach to
analyzing characteristics of those
estimators
so um the strategy is is the following
so uh
the first thing you need to do is is
find a fixed point for the gamp and for
the state evolution
and so
usually finding the fixed point of the
game just becomes kind of a
like
solving a set of linear equations so
it's straightforward
once you've found the fixed point
you sort of need to consider a
stationary gap and so the idea is that
the stationary gap
is initialized via an
oracle so it's initialized you know with
something that
uses the signal that you want to recover
so it's no longer like a feasible
algorithm to run in practice but it's
for theoretical purposes it's it's nice
and so once you um initialize with the
oracle
what you can ensure is that the state
evolution is stationary so you kind of
uh initialize the algorithm such that
the state evolution starts at its fixed
point and so then as the algorithm
iterates it the state evolution remains
at its fixed point so
uh with the stationary algorithm right
now your game theory says that
every you know estimate bt from the
algorithm
has uh the the distribution that's given
by these
you know
state evolution fixed points right you
initialize in such a way that
the state evolution stays the
same and so kind of um the hard part
of this general strategy is actually
showing that
you know the stationary gap converges to
the fixed point right so
you have a fixed point of the game but
do we know that the game gets there if
we we run it
and so um
what you'd like to do is
show that this is true in the sense that
um something like this happens so you
know if we have a fixed point that's x
hat and this x hat t is you know the the
iterate of my gamp algorithm then what i
want to show is that you know in this
sort of
high dimensional limit and then
as we run the algorithm limit
uh the mean square error between these
two goes to zero
and so um
once you have this
then uh you know
what do you have well your your a p
algorithm
converges to the the fixed point and we
know that the fixed point is the
minimizer of the cost function so now we
know some statistical properties of the
minimizer of the cost function based on
the state evolution
and so it turns out that this is like
um
proving this is is not too hard if
your cost function is strongly convex
uh with high probability around the
solution and around the amp iterates
essentially you just have to show some
sort of cauchy property in the sense
that the iterates of the amp are getting
closer together
um
and you also have to to show that you
know your cost is approximately
minimized by
you know the output of your your amp so
uh
the way you know one could can do this
is show that you know if you have
something in the sub gradient of your
cost evaluated at that point then the
norm of that sub gradient is is small
and so this is kind of the non-trivial
part of the whole thing
um
especially when you know you don't have
the strong
convexity assumption so if you have
strong convexity then
you're
more or less done here but if you don't
then there's some extra work to show
that it's unlikely that this subgradient
is small
and you know that this guy remains large
and so that's
usually the the subtle argument in most
of these
um cases
and so um
i don't know i was gonna uh end by by
going through
uh you know these steps for the lasso
problem but that's probably going to
take me a while so um
i'll stop here but you know if anybody's
interested uh i'm happy to like go
through the steps at some other point
you know just catch me like in the
coffee room or something um so i will
stop here thanks so much for here
[Applause]
all right thanks so much cindy for a
really really excellent
tutorial um i guess we'll take questions
now
for the convergence to the fixed point
can we also show like a stronger
property because like if we want to use
amp performance as the computational
frontier we would want like you know
with polynomially many iterations
like to recover the signal
in the
convergence uh you killed the acid
product one like can you show a stronger
one like you know it converges in like
polynomially many steps
yes i
think
yeah so you have to have this
going
first right um so that
means yeah
how crucial is to go center can you go
beyond the sanity here because i mean at
least the the what you worked out
carefully it seemed like really
restability on the rotation variant yes
so
[Music]
yeah so i mean
uh
so there i mentioned briefly that
there's been some works extending
beyond the gaussian so you know um
if the matrix a is not gaussian but
instead it's
right rotationally invariant or
something it can go through but you
still need the rotation right
yeah so they're they can extend the like
iid subgaussian um but you know
like
it's in practice the ant algorithms work
um
for example if it's like a fourier
transform matrix or something so uh are
often workers so
they seem to
in practice work more widely than what
we've proved here um and i think like to
extend the theory you might have to
you know
have a different proof
technique than what i showed because
like you're saying it's really like
rotationally invariant
uh
you know
it's important that that property is
there
so awesome
so also the i think i mean
the
general's linear model which you didn't
show the details i guess also the
rotational variant is crucial there also
so i need the data to be yeah
but for instance you can do iap gas
shuttles
but where each
so
cancer or
something up to the condition or
something
now titan said it becomes more and more
complicated
but you you still have to you have to
know the covariance structure
so like in the state evolution
characterization like how many equations
sort of go in there like what are the
parameters that's going to you know the
covariance structure is going to come in
there so you might have no equation
things like balloon to get like uh nasty
enough that you won't show them on a
slide pretty quickly
you start generalizing
but i think it's also like this
philosophy people understand correctly
you're trying to
eventually kind of reduce everything to
one dimensional problem
so you can't need some type of symmetry
for this even if not full spherical
symmetry
but again you know if you do for
instance the last so we died
the point is that this fixed price
equation now to speak the point
instead of having the
expectation of respect when
they see a gaussian
it becomes expectation in the dimensions
so now this becomes
very complicated about
the certain point you're right the the
utility of these cells finishing
so yeah you have to find anything
but so it seems that if they have like i
know like sparse variants or like some
hierarchically structured covariates
then these things
seems
correct that this would not be the right
tool or
is there still hope of
like things that are really
non-rotational variants variant
[Music]
no no sorry
uh
b by and going to constant
uh instead of a parallel approach gives
similar results usually so in that case
for some problems you can extend to the
finite rank
but you can extend to one white kind
oh you can write it for any sigma but
then sort of if you want like very
tractable equations
right scalar equations then there are
some cases where it's explicitly worked
out but even without that
we
the equations and then the theory
follows from like the non-separable
right so yeah
[Music]
we know any other
so the question is like
is there any other algorithm that
performs as well as amp
for doing like
the lowering matrix estimation problem
that's cheap
i don't know anybody in the room have a
you could imagine specifying right so
just some sample uh
gets nothing because this is
each single entries
matrix that approximate this matrix and
then do everything with that
fantastic so let's think
uh